from uh our friends at nbc sports uh
joining us right now peter king how are
you peter
rich how are you doing today wow
there's lots to talk about pk i'll tell
you that so
um you were you were you just get off
the phone with cal mcnair the ceo of the
houston texans i talked to him about it
i talked to him about an hour ago i
think he's doing a little media tour
and uh his quote to adam is almost the
same as his quote to me
and i quote cal mcnair there's been a
lot of
misinformation out there and i'll just
sort of leave it at that
but desean is a texan and i expect him
to remain a texan
and i'll just sort of leave it at that
that is his exact quote
so um i did not expect anything
different than that
um nick casario does not want
as his first uh
major move as a as an nfl general
manager
the move that will follow him the rest
of his career
so he does not want to trade
desean watson uh as he
takes over this new and daunting job
and it isn't only that i mean are you
ever really going to get value
for a 25 year old franchise quarterback
um very rarely has this happen in nfl
history
you know steve young was traded from
tampa to san francisco
in 1987 but and he was supposed to be a
franchise quarterback
but he had been awful in tampa so they
got a two and a four for him
and fran tarkington was traded from the
vikings to the
giants for two ones and two twos
uh in the late 60s um and but he wasn't
what desean watson is
so i would expect and if i were nick
casario and it ever comes to this
every conversation is gonna have to
start with your incumbent quarterback in
three ones
uh and that's where it's going to start
my belief
that if i were general manager i
wouldn't trade them without getting four
ones and a quarterback
in return then again though uh peter
things might be out of your control
do you think nick casario would have
wanted j.j watt to be allowed to walk
out of the building for nothing
no but that's a totally totally
different story
it's jj watt has been one of the most
legendary
athletes of this century because of
everything he's done and raising 41
million dollars for houston
uh to uh
you know to combat the hurricane five
years ago
uh he he is and he's played 10 years
and you could argue this a guy who is
who has missed
uh 32 games in the last five years
yeah you're going to get something for
him but i doubt
it in his age 32 season
that you're going to get i would be
almost certain you wouldn't get a one
for him
but you could have definitely gotten
something but i totally
absolutely unequivocally support
what the texans did i see everybody on
twitter
who does not put the human element in
this at all
jj watt asked to be released
he has to be released so what are you
going to do play hardball and get the
73rd pick in the draft back
and get jj watt the best player in your
franchise history
to hate you forever because you traded
him to a place that he didn't want to go
i it's it's silly some at some point the
human element has to come in
no i i understand that uh peter i'm as
attuned to the human element as anybody
else and jj watt has earned it
but the texans are in a situation where
their star quarterback
uh needs to either a be gotten out of
dodge
or b made to understand
that there's a new regime and they're
going to try and win football games
and that they need him to do that
and they need to smooth whatever needs
to be smoothed over
to avoid that holdout situation
and to show jj watt the door for nothing
in return
when they could have basically told jj
maybe again this is fanciful potentially
hold on a second where do you want to go
and then you call up that team and say
we just need you can get him right now
for
five and i i know you think we we can
release him but
he's given us another spot where he
wants to go and
you know at least see if there's
something there right peter i mean
so you could at least tell desean we got
something
how would jake how would jj watt know
right now where he wants to go
i mean he doesn't know i mean i'm sure
if
i'm sure he would want to go to
pittsburgh let's say to play with his
brother
i don't even know that i'm sure he'd
want to go to green bay sure
but but again again again
this is about you're talking about a
four or
five to hold jj watt hostage basically
no
no for everything he's done for your
organization in my opinion
in my opinion whatever you would have
gotten in return would have been blood
money
peter king here on the rich eisen show
and i look i i
i love j.j watt and i i he deserves to
you know all the best and now he's going
to be going wherever he wants to go and
i came on the air with a list of all
teams that could use them and it's all
teams every last team could use them so
he's going into that spot
into that you know comfort zone right
now um
how what what what is the misinformation
do you think that cal mcnair is
referring to
and how in the world do they get desean
watson
sure what he thinks this is just my
guess yes okay
i i shouldn't say i'm sure but my guess
is that he thinks
that his relationship with sean watson
has been mischaracterized
when deshaun watson david mulliga his
agent
and cal mcnair had either a zoom meeting
or
a three-way phone call whatever it was
uh and and deshawn watson made it clear
that
he really wanted to have a say or he at
least wanted to
be in the conversation you know about
some of the future moves with this
organization
it seems that desean watson feels
that he was uh
he there was some subterfuge here and he
was never
told what was going to happen until
actually
nick casario was named and all i can
figure
and my guess is that that's not the way
that
uh that cal mcnair sees it but cal
mcnair cannot
gain anything today by publicly uh
saying that uh this you know i disagree
with
deshaun watson's characterization of
this event now
maybe it's something else i don't know
but i'm not a texans beat guy i'm just
looking at it from afar
yes and in my opinion in my opinion rich
you know it might get to a point where
it's going to be exceedingly ugly
but if i'm nick casario i'm just going
to say
we're not trading him this is this is
lunacy
we're not trading you we are we have to
fix this i mean rich
this is five months ago or whatever it
was six months ago
desean watson has a tearful press
conference thanking
everybody for uh you know giving him
this
mega contract five months later it's
over
it's just i don't know it's a little
precipitous
so at the very least i think
that nick casario and david cully need
to sit in a room
or a virtual room with him and have a
totally
absolutely a thousand percent off the
record conversation about where they are
peter king here on the rich eisen show
uh i i don't know peter
you know what i mean like and again i
just want to make clear
that i'm not sitting here saying the
texans shouldn't have just let
jj watt walk out the door because it's a
high-class gesture for a high-class
individual
they have a problem with their main guy
all right jj watt the reason why he they
say go
because you want out is because they
feel that he's given his time and
maybe his past great years are behind
him
deshawn's a different story there is
still a guy that they need to
smooth things over and to let their
heartbeat
walk out the door when their other
heartbeat is saying
i want out too and they're like no as a
matter of fact
forget it you know don't even think
about it
and then they come out and say there's
misinformation
and we could sit here and say that he
will sit down with everybody eventually
but you could see
from all the other reporting out there
that his people or people close to him
are talking about lists of other teams
and who's on it and who's not they're
not even close to setting a zoom meeting
is what it sounds like to me
and it how does that work out with the
new league year coming up right i mean
like right now
the jets are in the market maybe for him
and uh 49ers or he wants to go maybe to
the broncos
once the new league year hits and they
might go in another direction or
certainly the draft
there's no turning back there's no
turning back
on that you know i don't know if there's
turning back or not i
this is i would here's the point i would
make about
releasing jj watt versus
allowing uh or trading
desean watson okay when jj watt was 25
years old
uh that was in his uh
that was in his i'm just looking it up
right now because i want to be accurate
when he was 25 years old that was in his
that was in his age 25 season
in his fourth season in the nfl he had
20 and a half sacks
he was defensive player of the year for
the second time
and so i'm just saying
if jj watted walked into his owner's
office house wherever 2014
and said i want to be released or i want
to be traded they would have said
take a hike you know we're not doing it
this is a jj watt who now
as i said has missed 32 games in the
last five years due to injury
who's coming off a five-sack season in
16 games
and is not what jj watt was when he was
starting when he was 25 years old
that is what the difference here is
peter king here on the rich eisen show a
few more minutes left with the nfl
insider from nbc sports our colleague
here
on nbc sports on peacock and more um
there's no question trevor lawrence is
first overall
right or we saw urban just uh
chit-chatting with uh i mean literally
he and uh
dabble look like bffs this thing's this
thing's
this thing's a wrap the way this kid
looked i mean
where do you think we're still gonna get
maybe even anything from bulky or urban
just even even a a a slight hint of well
we're
we're we're still working on evaluations
or or this is just uh this is it
they're going to get hitched here i
doubt it but it reminds it reminds me of
last year when
uh washington with the second pick in
the draft
was trying to throw out everything in
the last two weeks that
they were thinking very seriously of
other people
other than chase young and it was a big
story in the last two weeks before the
draft
and sometimes it hurts
to cover a sport so maniacally
because you can talk yourself into
anything
you know i i would say this unless
unless
and it's absurd to think about it but i
mean you never know
unless russell wilson or deshawn watson
is traded to jacksonville you know for
some
package including that pig that would
bring trevor lawrence to
one of the other teams i i'm i'm not
going to devote too much
breath or or head space to thinking that
jacksonville might not take him so what
is worth the head space
uh on the quarterback carousel front
then peter
uh wence seems to have cooled um for the
moment
yeah um what else is called rich i think
honestly because
uh you know howie roseman is doing what
a a smart general manager has to do
there's no rush to this you don't have
to make your decision for another five
weeks until march 19th
third day of the league year so you
don't have to trade them now nobody's
doing anything now
there's no off season anything and
probably won't even be a regular
off-season anyway so
howie roseman can just sit there and
wait
until either chicago or indianapolis ups
its offer
i doubt it will be indy but that's just
an absolute gut feeling
i don't think they're as desperate even
though they really want once i don't
think they're as desperate as chicago is
going to be
and why is that that's a gut feeling too
you know why is that because you think
there's the draft as well
sitting out there i mean that's a big
major piece of the puzzle
because because ryan pace and matt
maggie have to win
yesterday and uh
and i don't think chris ballard i think
chris ballard and frank wright could
have a two and 14 season
and jimmy irsay would say i wouldn't
trade my two guys for anybody
that's the difference is there any there
there with jimmy g
in san francisco peter it just why does
that keep on
being churned up why does that keep
coming up well
because football is covered maniacally
but i also think that look
john lynch wouldn't be human
sitting there in his in his uh in his
old stadium in his old town
watching tom brady at 43 winning the
super bowl
he wouldn't be human if he didn't think
to himself
man if we went hard after brady if we
gave the full court press
we probably could have had them and you
know what maybe they could have i don't
know
but i just think that you have to
logically
look at jimmy garoppolo and say
listen unless there's a great offer a
great something
out there we're going to stick with
garoppolo
and he's going to be really good and
we're going to be happy with it it'll be
fine
but you can't ignore the injuries
you just can't and so i think
that if a golden opportunity came up
they think about it but
i kind of agree with you rich i i think
jimmy garoppolo is going to be the
quarterback of the niners opening day
last one for you peter you're the
perfect guy to ask because you're a
selector for the pro football hall of
fame
and uh you know you and i uh connected
um
as you were going through the selection
process a good couple of weeks before
the super bowl uh weekend when it
normally goes down and i was wondering
why that was the case and now i think we
we
have subsequently found out the answer
so david baker could wing
all over the the country in covid
and surprise even the unsurprisable
peyton manning and others
uh by sneaking up on him um in in you
being a new
news and information man who's in the
hall um
is this the greatest secret that's ever
been kept by anybody in the nfl
ever hey i was impressed
i never thought in a million years
they'd keep it and i had found out a
couple of things along the way but
you know i it's not my place to
spoil anybody's party but but uh
but i think i think it was a good thing
i mean look you want to have some
suspense about the hall of fame
it's kind of cool the one thing rich
i'll say that was really
interesting yes so i tune into nfl
honors
that night i'm sitting you know it's a
real exciting super bowl
mansion i go out and get a pizza at
about 5 30 or
or six o'clock i'm with you go right
back to your hotel
tampa yep and then i come back to my
room
and i got my pellegrino and uh and i'm
just watching tv
that's it but anyway i'm with you anyway
uh but
i do think the one there was one
surprise for me
i don't know i guess i was a little
naive there was a
pretty good movement this year for clay
matthews
not the packer of a few years ago his
you know his dad and the guy who i think
was the
signature brown of the 80s early 90s
went on to
i mean he was 40 years old he led the
falcons and sacks
in his second home i think he was a
really excellent football player for a
long time
played more games at linebacker than
anybody in the 101 year history of the
nfl
and i thought he had a real chance and
when i didn't hear his name called
that night i was slightly surprised not
shocked
slightly surprised but that was the one
i had sort of wished
that he would have gotten in but hey i'm
one of 48
so good for everybody who got in peter
thanks for the call
truly appreciate it let's uh let's chat
in just a couple weeks and
when more will no doubt be popping
appreciate your two cents
sounds good rich all the best to you
right back at you at peter underscore
king
nbc sports nfl insider